-Your new show
is about rejecting shame
and learning to embrace
who you are.
-Yeah, I think it's
a nice alternative
to hating yourself all the time.
-Yes, it is.
Exactly.
I think that's great,
because sometimes people
just keep their emotions
bottled up inside,
even though it feels so much
better to let it out, you know?
-Yeah, yeah.
Well, have you ever tried
doing a "hey, world"?
-No, what is that?
-Oh, okay, well, "hey, world"
is when you shout your deepest
confessions and insecurities
out to the whole dang world.
You know, just own it.
It feels really great.
-Hm, interesting.
Can you show me how it works?
-Oh, sure.
So basically, you just look out,
and you scream something
that you've kept inside
for a long time.
So, like, I might say,
"Hey, world!
I once had a full
make-out session with someone
while a YouTube video
of rodeo bloopers
was on in the background."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, I feel better.
-Did that really happen?
-Yeah, baby.
-I want to get in on this.
Let's do this.
Hey, world.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ Hey, world ♪♪
♪♪ The world, the world ♪♪
♪♪ Hey, world ♪♪
-Hey, world.
My first time at the Emmys,
I was so hungry,
I ate a hot dog
in the lobby barefoot.
I'm gorgeous.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, world, the other day,
I plucked an inch-long hair
from my earlobe.
An inch-long hair
from my earlobe, world.
That shouldn't be possible.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, world!
I truly think that "diarrhea"
is a beautiful word.
And I would not rule out naming
my daughter or son Diarrhea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, world, my doctor told me
I have acid reflux
and I shouldn't eat spicy foods
before I go to sleep.
But the other night I ate
a giant bowl of penne in bed,
and then I put the bowl
on my end table and fell asleep.
I loved it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, world, when I was 5,
I did not understand
what hard-boiled eggs were.
I thought they were
going to hatch,
so I took some and I put them
in a bush in my backyard.
And for days I brought them
water and food.
And I would sing to them.
And then I went outside, and
they were covered in maggots,
and I screamed for my dad,
and I watched as he
shoveled away my children.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, world,
ever since I became a dad,
I basically stopped sleeping.
I am so tired all the time.
The other day, my daughter snuck
into bed with me and my wife,
fell asleep, and peed the bed.
I was so tired that I actually
thought to myself,
"If my wife doesn't wake up,
then I'm just going to keep
sleeping in pee-soaked sheets."
That's how badly I need sleep.
I don't care if I sleep in pee!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, world,
it's Aidy and Jimmy.
We're going to do this one
together because why not?
It feels good to have a friend
you can shout stuff
to the world with.
I'll admit it hurts our voices
a bit, but it's totally worth it
because it's fun and cathartic,
okay?
That's it.
That's everything.
We're done now.
See you later.
-Bye, world!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
I feel so much better!
Aidy Bryant, everyone.